6 Uhr morgens zwei Nächte in Folge hat
Bojan vor dem Stuttgarter Ausländeramt
übernachtet mehr als 30 Stunden am Stück
steht er mit seiner Frau nun schon an
ganzen Tag gestern ganzen Abend heute um
ganze Abendessen
es ist nicht normal dieser junge Mann
will nicht erkannt werden er versucht
heute schon zum dritten Mal einen Termin
zu kriegen gestern nach der Arbeit bin
ich hierher gekommen um 19 Uhr ich war
bis 21:30 Uhr da dann ist mein Bruder
aus Niedersachsen gekommen damit ich
schlafen kann bis fünf ich habe zu Hause
geschlafen in dieser Zeit und mein
Bruder war für mich hier
auch er hat über Nacht draußen ausgehart
muss dringend seine
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung verlängern lassen
online einen Termin vereinbaren geht
hier nichts
manche sind schon seit zwei Tagen hier
manche sind den dritten Tag hier aber es
ging nicht es ist nicht einfach das ist
die kurze Zusammenfassung aber wir sind
hoffnungsvoll dass heute einige von uns
dran kommen
das Ziel aller hier eine der wenigen
Einlasskarten verteilt von einem
privaten Sicherheitsdienst doch die sind
heute erstmal vergriffen noch bevor die
Behörde um 8:30 Uhr überhaupt aufmacht
jetzt bin ich erstmal fertig
viele hier werden auch heute wieder
unverrichtete Dinge gehen müssen trotz
stundenlanger Wartezeit oder den ganzen
Tag und noch die nächste nach dir
verbringen in der Hoffnung dass es
vielleicht morgen klappt
bundesweit sind viele Ausländerbehörden
derzeit massiv überlastet in Stuttgart
sagen viele sei es besonders schlimm die
Behörden stellen zum Beispiel Dokumente
für Flüchtlinge aus aber auch
Arbeitsvisa für nicht EU-Bürger für
Fachkräfte also die zum Beispiel in
diesem Krankenhaus dringend benötigt
werden
wir rekrutieren speziell für Bereiche
wie den Operationsbereich oder die
Intensivstation wo wir in großen
Fachkräftemangel haben da kommt es auf
jede einzelnen Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter an und wenn die fehlen
müssen wir betten sperren Operationen
fallen aus wir haben jetzt in der
letzten Zeit einige Mitarbeiter deshalb
verloren weil wir einfach nicht mehr die
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung hatten ein echtes
Problem von den 3000 Mitarbeitern haben
800 einen ausländischen Pass ohne sie
bricht der Betrieb hier zusammen Glück
haben die die erstmal keinen Termin beim
Ausländeramt brauchen ich habe meine
Unterlage vorher gut bekommen für vier
Jahre deswegen musste ich nicht mehr in
Ausländerbehörde gehen eine Freundin von
mir muss heute Nacht Ausländerbehörde
gehen weil sie hat bis jetzt keine
Termine gehabt trotz die Ausweis ich
schon abgelaufen Fälle wie diesen kennen
Sie auch hier Ausweisdokumente
Arbeitsgenehmigungen die Auslaufen
obwohl die betroffenen Mitarbeiter davor
wochenlang versucht haben das
Ausländeramt zu erreichen
24 Stunden 5 Liter wir haben mit der
Stadt vor einiger Zeit ich meine das war
so vor anderthalb Jahren vereinbart dass
wir Notfallnummern bekommen dass wir in
solchen Einzelfällen auch intervenieren
können nur auch diese Notfallnummern
funktionieren im Moment nicht mehr weiß
kein Personal mehr dort gibt und damit
sind wir jetzt gelähmt was dieses Thema
angeht sich Versuche per Anruf
durchzukommen E-Mails die vom Amt nicht
beantwortet werden davon berichten auch
viele die hier in der Schlange stehen
fast 30.000 E-Mails seien derzeit
unbeantwortet sagt die Stadt Stuttgart
auf zdf-anfrage ein E-Mail hatte ich
schon vor einem Monat geschrieben fünf
Tage nachdem ich mein Studium
angeschlossen habe und seitdem warte ich
auf Antwort
ich schicke schon seit dem 8 August
Mails und Termine zu bekommen ich habe
nichts gehört ich habe auch versucht
anzurufen niemanden erreicht ich bin
seit 20 Jahren verheiratet mit einer
Japanerin wurden seit acht Jahren in
Deutschland um zwei Kinder haben seit
zwei Monaten versucht einen Termin zu
bekommen um die Aufenthaltsgenehmigung
zu verlängern rein formal ist sie ab
morgen nicht mehr
also hat sie eigentlich keine
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung mehr daher stehen
auch Sie in dieser notfallschlange für
besonders dringende Angelegenheiten doch
warum ist das Ausländeramt so
überfordert der zuständige Bürgermeister
sagt hauptgrund sei an massiver
Personalmangel wir haben knapp 30
Prozent unbesetzte Stellen dann kommt
noch Urlaub und Krankheit obendrauf das
bedeutet wenn Sie sich vorstellen von
zehn Schreibtischen sind drei nicht
besetzt aber es liegen trotzdem Akten
drauf und stapeln sich dass wir eine
erhebliche buchwelle vor uns herschieben
und diese buchwelle beschäftigt uns und
wir schaffen es bei dieser Personallage
auch nicht wieder abzubauen und vor die
Lage zu kommen sondern werden durch den
Personalmangel eben gebremst in dem was
wir ein Output leisten können dass ich
das dringend ändern muss fordern
inzwischen vielen auch die Wirtschaft
sagt so kann es nicht weitergehen
vielfach können auch
Beschäftigungsverhältnisse fertig
abgeschlossene Verträge nicht angetreten
werden weil der Aufenthaltstitel nicht
schnell genug dann erteilt wird und für
die Betriebe ist es ein enormes Problem
dass diese Verfahren teils Monate fast
gab es zu einem Jahr dauern können doch
wie kann die Situation verbessert werden
denn zur Erinnerung nicht nur in
Stuttgart ist die Ausländerbehörde
überlastet IHKs und Handwerks kann man
arbeiten den Städten nun vielerorts zu
um Verfahren zu beschleunigen in
Stuttgart bemüht die Stadt sich
inzwischen außerdem intensiv ein neues
Personal zu kommen wir bilden verstärkt
aus wir nehmen mittlerweile auch
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeiter die jetzt
nicht vom Fach sind sage ich die also
keine gelernten
Verwaltungsfachangestellte sind was
natürlich aber in den erhöhten
Ausbildungsaufwand mit sich bringt und
wir setzen verstärkt und das hilft uns
auch wirklich Aushilfen ein die aus
anderen Bereichen kommen doch das
alleine reicht aus sich viele
Arbeitgeber nicht aus
sie haben noch wir haben uns da eine
Bürokratie mittlerweile aufgebaut die
kaum mehr zu beherrschen ist der
Vergangenheit konnten wir mit
entsprechender Expertise des
einigermaßen bewältigen und steuern und
jetzt üben wir einfach in einer
Situation dass es nicht mehr
funktioniert es gibt eine hohe
zweistellige Anzahl von
unterschiedlichen Verfahrensarten man
braucht nahezu ein Studium um überhaupt
diese Verfahren zu verstehen da ist der
Gesetzgeber der Bundesgesetzgeber
gefordert diese Verfahren zu
vereinfachen es wird eine enorme
Beschleunigung bringen und das zweite
ist tatsächlich eine konsequente
Digitalisierung der gesamten Verfahren
mehr Anstrengungen bei der
Digitalisierung der Ausländerbehörden
fordert auch das Bundesinnenministerium
von den Städten und Gemeinden man selbst
arbeite an rechtlichen Vereinfachungen
entsprechende Schritte sind im Beschluss
zur Besprechung des Bundeskanzlers mit
den regierungschefinnen und Chefs der
Länder vom 10 Mai 23 festgehalten und
wurden durch die Bundesregierung auch
umgesetzt bzw finden sich in Umsetzung
für die die in diesen Tagen stundenlang
warten müssen um eventuell dran zu
kommen ist das wohl nur ein schwacher
Trost denn ein schnelles Ende der
Schlange ist nicht in Sicht ja Sie
müssen sich dann halt am Tag vorher um 6
Uhr anstellen um eine Chance zu haben
Termin zu bekommen also es ist wirklich
einer Stadt Stuttgart nicht würdig wie
kann man selbst alle sehen was hier
steht einfach ich glaube das ist einfach
von menschlichen Würdigkeit und
definitiv kein gutes Bild das
Deutschland damit sendet an dringend
benötigte Fachkräfte aus anderen Ländern